the filchers madhouse and welcome to
punch-drunk sportswear winners win
it's a packed house here today joining
us from the kill Tony podcast
Tony hinge Club whoa Josh Martin oh hey
guys
Wow bringing that energy a bag of bets
Fame Josh Martin yes a hero in the pot
and the punch-drunk you know that was in
the past you should have sold that thing
on eBay
yeah you come right yeah I mean I mean
there's homeless meth heads a no enjoy
that [ __ ] ain't no one cloning the three
of us you ain't got to worry about that
you know kind of clone I'm gonna be on
since I wiped my face for that I don't
break out that much yeah there you go
there you go and dude after you did that
did you become a regular yeah yeah I
don't think your [ __ ] had dude in the top
that won't question the blessing that's
a conspiracy theory right there Sam's
coming has something to do with
everything yeah it's really the Swiss
Army knife of DNA that's what it is I
love it you and Josh actually sort of
look alike josh is like you if you got
hit in the head with an aluminum bat as
a kid I look like Fahim Anwar if I did
ten years of hard cocaine which I did so
it worked out I'm out definitely out
before and what it used to be um were
you guys gonna be dates out of the gates
I'm going to be at my friend Carl's
house next weekend do calls great and
not really and that's it that's it dates
out of the gates this is the thing I
love this some in Dallas two shows on
New Year's Eve all were you playing uh
hyenas I love which one Dallas or Dallas
that's food I love it man
he had me a sweet gig at the play no one
yeah it was awesome he's the man Randy's
the man out there it was like my third
time doing that Club this year so it's
crazy I can't believe he keeps having me
back but Dallas is a great town Dublin
kill Tony Manchester England kill Tony
and London kill Tony the tickets on sale
tomorrow so I'm so excited to be here to
announce to you know my you know second
or third favorite podcast in the world
punch-drunk bet those tickets are on
sale tomorrow plus I'm doing six
solo dates of the London Soho Theatre
awesome just my stand-up comedy all by
myself I guess they don't really do
openers and features out there just
walking out and right yeah and a lot of
other fun stuff
Philly kill Tony and stand up shows and
and Ralegh North Carolina Phoenix
Arizona Royal Rumble weekend I'm doing
we're doing a kill Tony there this
Saturday afternoon going to the Royal
Rumble on Sunday and I'm doing some
stand a stand-up show on Friday night
somewhere around the town like the whole
weekend it's crazy because when the
Royal Rumble goes to a city like a
hundred thousand people show up there
and it's a feel like it's even getting
like the all-star game Brody calls it
the black super ball yeah and the Royal
Rumble is like the white trash Super
Bowl rally and we are in it this is
gonna be our third year in a row yeah
we're that like that's like hitting
white trash with gamma radiations yeah
Ron beware the Diamondbacks play in a
baseball stadium Chase Field oh it's so
fun every year now I use my fancy agents
to get wrestling tickets that's
basically no one else is so funny no
it's true and they have a box at the
Staples Center and all this [ __ ] like
it's insane ask this kid I mean I've
taken us to every Staples Center us
women yeah it's so ridiculous I get like
it's basically like I look at it like a
write-off with my agent like it's like I
give them 10% oh the [ __ ] yani but I
get it almost all back and that's the
best temporal spend I get it back in pro
wrestling and that's great the six of us
or shows up and is just like one dude
with his son yeah and then it's just
this freak show with this guy's who's
the [ __ ] yeah we're gonna be Josh uh
tomorrow I'll be playing basketball at
the West Hollywood Park snaps and
Saturday I'll be jumping a fence of a
middle school to play basketball
Saturday that's great oh yeah I'm doing
Irvine January 3rd through the 5th -
that's a hard Club for me to fill all my
Latino fans yeah we should just throw a
bunch of Asians on there yeah just every
single Asian you can find throw them out
there that's that's all Orange County is
if any Asians or Mexicans want to open
up for me
just tweet that you're opening up even
though you're not yeah just get your
friends out get those amigos and amigas
out I love Mexicans
oh my only I like dude I'm taking
December off I'm not I just didn't
wanted to break the breeze so I have one
I have the comedy cast tonight both
sold-out and then the wall Friday my
second special Armageddon drops on Vimeo
man go check it out it's only a dollar
ninety-nine to rent or two three dollars
to own and it's a 40 minutes of killer
then you can go get zero Fox you those
are boom boom one two killer punch okay
and then Saturday night I got a show in
Chicago it's sold out we're doing
Haney's the 11 o'clock show we sold it
out it's like which one Oh Chicago the
yeah I don't know it's the downtown one
so I'm very excited
that's a our mo get Indian that's what
he went with no I get with zero Fox it's
like it's Sam Tripoli live from the
Viper Room if I was gonna name my
special after something Armenian I would
do like like I don't know like genocide
of fries or something like that right a
silly name I think Armageddon is a silly
name System of a Down to [ __ ] yeah I
like that one
it's just another down syndrome hahaha
so uh yeah man I'm super excited the
feedback has been great and it's going
well and it's just like it's a great man
I mean really the you guys sold it out
11 o'clock is such a late [ __ ] spot
and just cuz that's that's the shows we
get we literally set on suicide missions
and we do really well I mean someday
they'll give us ah the good spots but
until that day goes we'll take a week
it's a weekend alright no it's not we're
not in that town bars are open till 4:00
people don't even go late we're go
that's great yeah that's great you can
really yeah that'll be fine well god
bless it is that on a Saturday yeah it's
amazing yeah you're fine yeah
Saturday's rather have a Saturday and
eight well sure
look Saturday's they they hibernate in
that [ __ ] City 11alive there's no
between 11:00 and 6:00 p.m. in Chicago
in the winter yeah I mean it's it's
ridiculous
the The Saturdays that you got to worry
about is when people are having picnics
or going to the water oh yeah you don't
want to play a cold area during the
summer yeah nobody's coming inside not
til it's later in the summer unless
you're a Wayans brother like spring and
early summer yet everybody is just dying
to do [ __ ] outside but later in the
summer people kind of get back to doing
regular [ __ ] it's just like man you have
90 days where you can be outside in the
air I mean I have the worst luck in
Chicago any time I'm doing Chicago in
October that means they have broken a
curse and they're in the World Series
anyway I did it when the Blackhawks were
in the Stanley Cup I've done it when the
[ __ ] and everything every spoil
everything that's ever happened in
Chicago or really just any sporting
event I'm always in Chicago when it's
happening they're about to get another
one cuz the Bears are no joke that's the
story of my life on the road yeah it's
just like aw dude it's the pumpkin
festival yeah it's like it's pumpkins
and chicks show their tits
everybody's there you've been here last
week it was [ __ ] great everyone got
HBO specials under dicks up yeah when
Tony I were in Spokane it was like a no
one went to the shells on sadly because
of it like that's 5k yeah Sunday yeah oh
yeah they do the big run any any big
funny local event I'm the guy that gets
scheduled around another thing is like
sometimes big comedians will cancel
their weekend if they notice something's
off for example like I gotta which one
was that it was like it was just some
great [ __ ] Club it was like Portland
helium it's like one of my favorite
clubs that I've been like do for a
repeat at right and then I get a call
like the week before and they're like
hey dude you got Portland helium next
weekend a good deal if you want it I'm
like oh I'm not working next weekend
they're like no I'm like all right let's
do it
I guess Portland the uber driver when he
picked me up at the airport I'll never
forget this the uber driver goes so you
here for the show and I think he's a he
like knows me right and I'm like yeah
man all five of them right he goes oh oh
I thought he was only doing one show
it's like Kevin Hart's doing the biggest
Arena in the in the city's history
oh my near Portland and there's a lot
crossover
like well I did the math Pony or Kevin
it was another it was a guy that gave up
the weekend before I don't want to say
his name but it was another like top
black comedian right but he did not so
it was it worked out for me because
exactly we have no crossover that's what
of course Marc Grossman figured out he's
like who can I get that's the opposite
of Kevin there's a time where I'd go on
the road and just like Rogen was within
ten miles yeah you know and it's like
when I did the ATC festival this year
you know I'm like I'll do the show but
every but all my fans right our fans of
these guys too and they're a little
bigger than me
right so but they ended up being great
great shows but still it's like it's you
just never know it's such an it's also
it's also rough when it matches up right
and you know that these people could
have seen Rogen for ten more dollars a
mile down the street so then you're like
wow these this audience is stupid
yeah so now you're like wow right and if
they're laughing they're just like I
don't even trust you if you were really
comedy fancy seeing like I get always
booked in like the Super Bowl I don't
want to entertain anybody who's not
watching the super bright but this is
the these are the geeks yeah you know
you take it I'm like what are you doing
here this is the game this is the game
you're allowed to beat I remember one
time it was a NFC AFC championship game
so that's Saturday two games on a
Saturday and Falcons got knocked out of
the playoffs the we previous week and I
was just [ __ ] I just was so pissed
I'm like I'm not gonna watch these two
games [ __ ] these games [ __ ] the NFL I
mean my girlfriend went to Magic
Mountain
doing a FCN it's a championship game
I've never seen that place so dead like
everybody that was there was either a
gay or like I'll like a wife and she
took the kids while the husbands are
watching the game or whatever yeah we
would ride rides and it would pull in
and they would be like all right stay on
the ride if you want to ride it again it
could be no lines so you just ride a
roller coaster like three times in a row
we wouldn't even take our seat belt off
that's the great it was crazy dude
that's what Heaven's like yeah I imagine
you go somewhere like the Super Bowl you
go to like a Magic Mountain during the
Super Bowl they like
Disneyland yeah well there's people that
the guys that were working the rides and
[ __ ] they would look at me like dude you
know what today is right yeah like why
are you here oh it was like me and five
girls went yeah it's crazy although one
of them is my girl no I think all six of
you is just trolling for dick yeah hot
[ __ ] sandwiches but there's no dick
there was no dick there I literally say
the only guys no that's true yeah we're
all five women that you were with
divorced with kids I like those girls
you know I'm saying dude that's like a
nice oh yeah nice car they nice used car
with some miles on it right they know
how to keep a secret yeah and they're
over it you know they got that first
crack right there the armors a little
dented yeah that's what I do like that
there's nothing hotter than a sweet
ten-year-old right guys Wow a guy not a
girl Jesus I don't whistle if they made
actors like you know they stopped doing
cigarettes in in uh you know television
movies like nobody smokes what they
stopped actors from taking sips of
everybody uses as a crutch all they do
all day in every scene they do is
[ __ ] drink liquor yeah every [ __ ]
time there's a guy named ben mendelsohn
you know this guy he was in a show about
the Florida family that like inherited B
I know exactly you're talking about
dammit how can I not remember this
a famous Smith bloodline yeah bloodline
we've got some Star Wars right and in
every every scene in bloodline and every
movie that I've ever seen him in Animal
Kingdom like I don't know II can't
remember all the movies but he's an
amazing actor but he always has a glass
of like scotch and he makes it look so
good in every movie and I remember
seeing him in the one of the newer Star
Wars and I'm like wow I love this guy I
can't believe he's one of the bad guys
in this Star Wars this is funny because
it'll be definitely the first movie in
which he's not drinking in and then
three quarters of the way through the
movie he's on the [ __ ] Death Star
what
it is one of those super Imperial ships
and in the first it's got to be the
first time I've noticed in Star Wars
frickin history at one point he's
looking out the window and he turns
around and it pans long and there it is
this mf'er on the [ __ ] Death Star or
whatever we're in the cantina they
weren't I think that was a juice bar
yeah exactly it was like that was the
worst part about the UFC this past
weekend when max Holloway won he had a
monster energy cannon in his hand and he
pretends to drinking it's clearly empty
you can tell the cans empty but he's
still really pretending to drink it I'm
like you're Alek control that [ __ ] it's
just garbage no I love monster energy
drink the blue one low carb one that's
great it's really like I hate although I
can't separate any other gasoline I
can't even drink redbull
it's that taurine whatever that is in
that I don't just [ __ ] with me I'm a
taurine comedian Wow energy drink jokes
come on out London England sponsored
your tour look at you love her energy ah
so what do you want get into so much
great sports going on I want to talk
about the UFC and how there's something
going on with them either I mean they
this card was great and they did zero
promotions for it and it's almost like
when you play a comedy club and they're
like where is everybody I'm like you did
zero advertising you didn't even let
anybody know I was [ __ ] here what am
I can only do so much and it's like max
Holloway is a great great great MMA
fighter and they did no prep nothing on
this fight I don't they didn't see
anything running for it did they do good
I don't I mean I don't know what the
numbers are but I mean like I don't
think it anybody was buzzed about it I
think it's one of those ones to where
they probably knew that the biggest
fight fans were gonna watch you know
what I mean because it doesn't have a
Brock or a Connor or some identity
person right this is just this was a
card for real fight fans and I so I
could sort of see why they wouldn't blow
their load on that especially with some
monsters coming up I mean
not yet two weeks it's freaking cyborgs
Jonah's new Jones and yes officer
I think cyborg Nunez the real ones
that's a card you Ness is gonna get her
ass beat
yeah I think so I think dude I mean like
she's gonna put some stuff technically
but at the end of the day just nobodies
built like cyborgs right
she's the Wilt Chamberlain of female MMA
at what point did she start to get old I
it's gonna happen soon yeah I think that
that's a real battle of mental strengths
if cyborg gets popped once it could ring
a bell man she hears a you know ringing
inner ear for the first time ever in her
career we don't know how she'll respond
to that really right it's gonna take a
woman who is built like her to beat her
it's either gonna be a father time or
like another genetic super freak I think
Amanda's got a shot she was Nunez was in
the corner for that one girl this
weekend at the fight she was in her
corner and she was massive much bigger
than ever so I guess they're out like is
this a different way disease yes massive
need it built like uh like like a like a
totem pole like it's like she's like
stout I think it kind of depends on the
if cyborg how much weight cyborg needs
to lose if she has to drain lose a lot
of weight to make weight then I think
that's a chance I mean she's had enough
she has enough time I mean she has
enough time there's no excuse she's been
waiting for a fight forever and this
fight there's now a lot of fights left
for her she's that good but cyborg
always struggles to make weight on every
previous fight she barely made weight
her last fight she was about to die
basically yeah whadya and it also makes
it's that you have a much weaker chin
and my point is if Nunez goes into this
playing it too safe like oh this is
cyborg if she gives her too much respect
she's gonna be [ __ ] if she goes in
there and is able to do with her what
she did with Ronda and be like this
[ __ ] just got beat I can handle her she
went in with that mentality I'm Ronda
and some mashed her if she gave Rhonda
respect that fight that would have given
Rhonda a chance if she good chance
because Rhonda was like champion when
everybody was doing Tae Bo you know they
they you were ranked top ten because you
were one of ten women who were in a
female MMA it wasn't that yeah the
competition the competition is way
better now I mean you were getting
especially these third-world chicks like
these Polish chicks they got nothing
right their best chances become a good
MMA fighter it's like that or porn those
are their two options to get out of
whatever poverty they're doing she I
mean like that's why they kept cyborg
out of the UFC because they knew she
would annihilate Ronda Rousey yeah and I
have no problems with Ronda Rousey you
know it's like hey did you took
advantage of a situation you're doing
great and rut is she doing great in
wrestling good at acting is killing it
yeah she's really good it's not really
acting acting I mean look at Brock
Lesnar it's like is he good at acting I
don't know but when you're a good guy
she is she's a little bit of both yeah
she was like a good guy with with an
edge yeah is she the champion yeah that
didn't take long
well now I mean they're paying her crazy
amounts of money in her and she's gotta
be loving it she's got that Brock affect
a man she's doing a really good job
she's doing different moves she's using
her judo stuff we've never really seen
in pro wrestling just like fricken
tosses and crap over and over again like
David they're making her character
really fun to watch and she's taking
some big bumps it was a chair on what we
went to our series Survivor Series there
was a chair round Rousey's neck and
would you show the Flair just stomped on
it do you guys watch wrestling as basic
theater like Broadway there if you're
watching it by yourself it's almost
weird that's how I look at it like I
love watching it with comedians and it's
there's nothing funnier Vince McMahon
such a genius that it's literally the
most untalked about thing in sports
history is how this guy is able to make
us all laugh every week well right but I
mean I guess it's somewhere they but
these but the athletic [ __ ] that they're
doing is more athletic than a lot of the
stuff that you'll see sometimes
and one of the things you know and I get
it being a fan of UFC and pro wrestling
a massive fan of both is crazy but the
two elements that clash or you know
sometimes you don't know if you're gonna
get a great fight in the UFC
whereas with WWE you know that they're
going so we saw make it great no matter
what and but that's what UFC does is
they they talk [ __ ] to make to create a
story to increase paws around a fight
which is just what WWE does yeah for all
them like the genre now or do you mitt
the era now or do you like I'm I miss
the old day of school you know everybody
had a dad bod Yeah right coming in
hungover and we're just great salesmen I
love that well I missed the Attitude Era
back in the you know late 90s what can
be said about the UFC is right you know
it's right you know it's big stars but
back in the day it was more outlaws and
the two things aren't that different you
know what I mean look at this Ben Askren
situation for example you want to know
what that is bro that's stone-cold
versus Vince so the fight fans that are
real UFC fans that are insiders are like
man seems like Dana hates Ben Askren
right Ben's like Dana hates me won't
follow me on Twitter he throws me Robbie
Lawler he just had to hire me because
Joe and Brendan were talking about me
right well there's just theory that they
brought him in to take out on khabib
like how do you beat a bad man with
another bad man yeah that would be a
great fight they could do a catchweight
oh yeah that'd be a great it's coming
it's coming
another one would be Nate Diaz could be
but I got Nate [ __ ] and believe it or
not I got Nate being able to win that
fight I think khabib takes down Nate and
then what he's in the mousetrap bro yeah
but I mean like dude khabib is it's
possible to go he's getting there I mean
he comes from where Dagestan yeah like
they have MMA fights on the corners of
Street like everybody just fights there
that's all they do it's literally just
fight and he's the best of that so even
as you know you got what was this
competition when he was you know he's 28
know like dude he went up against
savages from day one yeah and now he's
undefeated and like do
he's come pretty far I mean like to be
the champ and just a Connor I don't know
man we'll see what happens most of his
wins came against guys he were he was
bigger than at the 145 and even at the
155 he was bigger than those guys so
it's just like now he's taking he's
going up against big dudes now and he's
struggling but with that said Connor
also had to cut that weight you know
that's a massive weight cut being bigger
is a blessing and a curse you know what
I mean so even though he was bigger he
did cut down and was able to do crazy
stuff yeah I don't people get confused
when I am more excited about Nate Diaz
or khabib against Connor but it's just
cuz they're two of the few that I think
can beat Connor you know I mean I think
John Connors more beautiful than could
be oh definitely
doubting there's all there's a handful
of people that could probably be Connor
regularly and I don't I struggle to
think of somebody that can [ __ ] with
could be UFC has to be very cautious how
they they they handle Connor from here
they you know they have shown over and
over again an inability to set their
stars up for success they consistently I
like it whatever you want to say about
Bellator they know how to throw a good
tomato can they'll throw somebody in
there and you're like there's no way
this guy's winning and the guy goat
moves on and builds builds built UFC
they'll throw everybody into trouble
right out the gate look at Brock Lesnar
comes in fights a juiced-up Alistair
Overeem after getting half his [ __ ]
carved out I like that aspect of it
though well dude I don't want to make a
business it's bad for business but I
feel like Connor vs. khabib the fight
should have been Connor versus Anthony
Pettis Tony Ferguson versus khabib
because if you Tony Ferguson loses it's
not gonna hurt the bottom line as much
as Connor losing and people wondering
how much he's still into this whole
thing you know I mean I think Connor is
a much easier fight versus Anthony
Pettis anthe Pettis is a striker hasn't
been the same since all these since they
started having these really stringent
drug tests and he's way more beatable
than ever to me like it's a Fanta
if they did that I'd be everyone's just
gonna [ __ ] like oh he should be
fighting beep if he's the best and
khabib is the best that's what I'd want
to see I don't know she wants me to quit
in two year layoff still the problem is
having to be Connor already fight is
that I no longer really care about kabhi
Ferguson anymore I do I'm excited I want
to see it but I think I would enjoy it
more if I saw that before there are
other people think Tony Ferguson has a
real chance against khabib I think so I
think a Biebs real problem is jiu-jitsu
I think eventually when he gets up
against a true black belt jiu-jitsu guy
then where does the wrestling lead you
that's what's so fun about UFC right is
you find a guy with the wrestling power
to bully a striker like Conor McGregor
but then what the style the the thing
that's gonna beat khabib is gonna be a
[ __ ] triangle or an armbar some or a
choke it's gonna come from him taking a
person down and then getting stuck so I
don't know if that's really Toni's main
thing right but I think eventually Cubs
gonna run into somebody now I just heard
any bobble go hold my beer you know
because they do train together and that
um what is the style fighting that that
arm could be does it's not it's not
wrestling it's all bear fighting no
there's a but it's not judo it's um
anybody
nope nobody knows yeah it said style he
wore shirt said if blah blah blah was
easy it'd be called jiu-jitsu he talks
mad [ __ ] on jiu-jitsu who khabib yeah
match it well I mean that's how you end
up getting [ __ ] choked out right
there it's gonna be interesting dude
it's gonna be [ __ ] interesting let's
see if Jon Jones can't [ __ ] this up and
get to the fight actually that's a real
fight man Gustafson give me a break
dude that guy guy is long dude he's long
yeah that's the first time Jon Jones
gets him with a guy that is as long as
him
they fought before though didn't it yeah
and it was really close but that was a
different Gustafson since then he's
taken beatings I saw Rumble Johnson put
a fist through room once in Sweden
yeah yikes yeah you want
turning out the lights oh that's gotta
be the worst Anthony Johnson and turn up
the lights he pulled the lever from
ghostbusters where the guys like I'm
gonna release these ghosts and the
Ghostbusters like don't do that and the
guys like oh I'm gonna show you cuz he
wanted to be boss he released the
goddamn ghost turn it up Oh lights but
releasing the ghost
I saw Rumble this weekend actually he
was he was trolling around the event in
Toronto like weigh-ins and stuff still
one of the scariest human beings do you
want to talk about a smart guy that got
out before getting his cuz he realized
what he was doing to these guys and he
probably knew Nakano and some people
were coming up he had probably done his
research he's like I'd like to retake
this time to retire it's like goodbye
sir job I mean the fact that that guy
got down - what'd he get down 170 at one
point crazy frightening unbelievable you
see number one on your list of dude you
don't want walking banging your girl ah
yes number one Frances Ngong for one I
mean what do you do what do you do just
sit there in jerk ah if Nogami [ __ ]
your girl that [ __ ] is ruined that
pussy's never getting back to normal you
walk in on the Gandhi [ __ ] your wife
all you want to do at that point is like
help lubricate the things make sure he
doesn't rip anything I'm gonna divorce
I'm married no race traitor shame on you
I'm telling your father oh man I don't
know man it's gonna be interesting to
see dude
and now just saw one Fc just signed a
big deal with t and t they're gonna
start doing fights there something's
definitely happening you know I thought
I I really honestly believe that the UFC
is working with Bellator
because they have these this monopoly
thing going on with the US government
and whether they're violating a labor
laws you know causing you know saying
these guys are independent con
tractors but basically they have to file
all these rules like you know they
basically [ __ ] him on on sponsorship
so I thought they were like funneling
these guys to the belt or to build up
belt or you know I mean look how many
people leave UFC go rate to Bellator
but now you see you have one FC blown up
it might be that there's gonna be a
couple of even watching what I see fight
oh that yeah they're out of Asia but now
they just signed a big deal with TNT
competitions good for everybody it's the
old it's the old thing I mean
everything's booming and
this deal the UFC made with ESPN
legitimizes the sport so much I think
they're dancin devil and the more people
realize that the UFC is a perfect sport
once they realize oh I get it so that
guy wrestles so he can take down the
puncher and oh that guy knows jujitsu so
the wrestler could be in trouble
oh you can't have any holes in your game
anymore right it's a perfect sport so
the people that love football it's too
much to pay attention it was my calling
those fights who's gonna be calling the
fights in the future and UFC for ESPN oh
that's a great question it's a great
question if they get some of that listen
to me ESPN if you get some of these
ding-dongs that don't know the [ __ ]
sport if it's [ __ ] any any of the you
know any of them oh we got a girl who is
into you know whatever you know they're
gonna do it oh yeah well that is why
ESPN does they want to give it in that
ultimately hurts the sports they work
with they deal with baseball they did
with the NFL and once one of these guys
smacks around one of these chicks the
ESPN is gonna go hard in the paint or or
maybe gets busted for steroids hard
that's what ESPN does they don't the
football with [ __ ] domestic violence
which is obviously something important
and then a head trauma who beats women
better UFC fighters or NFL players I
mean is who makes a living striking you
got figured they do combos that's a good
point
you know yes you tell me UFC fighters
beating women or NFL players beating
women yeah
I mean they're both doing God's work if
you ask me why many people think all
these all the way men deserve it
not all of them but it's [ __ ] a lot
of them let's be honest
Christ dude I can't condone that yeah I
thought she look I with that I was
thinking he was gonna show up with a
black eye yeah we are
every time she fights hell yeah hold up
away class she does have to work on her
jujitsu me tell you something Shevchenko
could easily be the one going up against
cyborg on the [ __ ] that's what that's
well I thought I'm like I would love to
see her in cyborg people you probably
will she's a big girl
that would not that would not not be
close Shevchenko would do more damage
than anybody else ever has cyborgs gone
up against nobody when I say nobody I
mean nobody she says she hasn't seen
anything in Holly Holm sort of janky
dude Holly Holmes either they're two to
get fighter of the night fight of the
Night bonus or nothing at all well she
was the perfect person beat Ronda Rousey
because she was just a pick and pop
person and Ronda just comes at you and
she hit her with the kick uh Holly Holm
cyborg was a good fight but Holly lands
one of those kicks on cyborgs [ __ ] just
changed the whole dynamic changes she
lands a one-two and is setting up for
that don't think that anybody has is
what every power to take out cyborg at
this moment it's just what everybody
says until they see it again I think
Nunez can [ __ ] do it well my point is
though is yes I agree with you it was my
favorite yo on a fight ever and it's the
only loss I've ever seen her take and
you've ever taken and and Shevchenko is
a [ __ ] monster so the fact that
Yoanna coming first ever by the way no
one even said this in the entire thing I
brought it up to Jo afterwards he's like
yeah that is true I go he's Yoanna the
first ever female to move up a weight
class yes and no it wasn't even like a
acknowledged thing and that's up
[ __ ] big deal Holly Holm moved up to
fight cyborg yeah but that was a [ __ ]
and that's like two weight classes no
it's no it's no she went from 105 to 145
I thought she went from oh yeah but
anyway it's still different when you're
coming from the lowest weight class up
it's it's a different bump than a
heavyweight fight and that was money
five yeah I was impressed with how much
bigger uh you know Johanna looked yeah
and healthier she was gaining momentum
in the fourth and fifth at fight goes
another round it's like it was just
takedown she just struggled on takedowns
every time she kicked she catched a leg
tripper and now she's on normally she
doesn't get in that type of trouble but
Shevchenko's so powerful that when it
comes to wrestling if you're wrestling
someone that just has a smaller mass
than you and you're doing the move and
you're both doing the right thing the
stronger person will win yeah of course
so but still even then she's popping
right she was popping back up getting
off of a bigger woman you know they were
talking about it this UFC about if a
wrestler takes you down and doesn't
really do much damage why should the
judges give you that many extra points
and I think that she utilized that she
knew what she was doing but also she was
it was just a great fight she was a lot
of it was less fire stronger firepower
with Shevchenko with less landing and a
lot landing with Johanna with less
firepower so yeah just a shootout of
styles yeah I don't know why I like with
these female fighters with if they want
to move up a weight class just get
pregnant boom I mean all the problem and
you got two girls that are pregnant
fighting each other I would watch two
pregnant UFC fighters might are just
[ __ ] laughs they're like ten months
pregnant I'm totally down for that what
happened to you what's bad about that
what you get [ __ ] molested at the
Comedy Store last night what's bad about
that what is bad about that you clearly
just said if I walk in and some black
guys banging my wife I'm just gonna
start jerking off that's fine I want to
see two pregnant chicks fighting and
Achtung okay you're saying those are the
same thing same equally outlandish
equally
not even close whoa dude
welcome to UFC double abortion Oh see
that's great now yeah now we're talking
yeah but like this is the big thing
about a female MMA is it gets Rousey how
weak it was now there's two new
divisions in within a year yeah there's
two new divisions many divisions as they
can the UFC needs more divisions do we
avoid any weight women that's healthier
for the fighters every ten pounds every
five pounds just do it man ten would be
fine that's a lot healthier for the
fighters because now you know just
because certain people have body types
where they can't like Pat Barry was
always heavyweight he was never gonna
win he's too short but maybe if they'd a
little and like you go 205 and then go
all the way up to 245 is the next limit
there's so many boom boom booms within
there you could have another champion
and especially seeing that it seems they
can only sell a fight if there's a title
fight why not have more titles yep right
I mean look at boxing this [ __ ]
somebody got ISM of every fighter has a
belt yeah yeah that but that's the
problem in boxing that so many titles
that you don't care about the tie it was
a problem with boxes there's no brand of
excellence there's no NFL NBA you know
UFC UFC you're assuming these are the
best of the best
yeah that's why you tuned into it yeah
yeah the most exciting ones in boxing
are the unification ones were like you
have two of the belts I have the other
three and then my core mates and talked
about was one of the grace to do it I I
talk about it all the time
I advise I think he I think you hear
that it's really weird how he's the bad
guy the John Jones Cormier phew
like they love John Jones no matter what
John Jones I think that tide has changed
there's a little bit there's so many
such a sport of frontrunners it's such a
[ __ ] you it's sport it originally John
Jones was still doing it when the
original UFC fans that are a lot of them
are just [ __ ] we're doing it like
lead bro sure you doesn't matter what he
does outside of the Octagon look what he
does inside the Octagon
here you sound like a New York City
sports radio guy I'll give a [ __ ] what
you like done that's the one Super Bowl
[ __ ] forever right yeah um I'm a huge
DC fan he's the smartest fighter usually
he's lost the one guy he's just weird
how you just see it like Joanna just
like at that way class she can't be the
thug ro yeah she can't be everybody else
including women that have beat thug row
yeah it's weird
that's that's weird that's what I'm
saying that's the best thing about the
sport is the crazy stylistic differences
I love it dude I think eventually it'll
get to a point where being undefeated
especially in MMA is it [ __ ] good
what Matt I agree with you shouldn't
mean anything yeah because it's time to
meet everybody once that somebody
everybody wants that quad is unbeatable
the minute Ronda Rousey got knockout
everyone who just jumped off the boat I
mean Kabir's fought some savages well
usually when you see somebody who's
undefeated it's usually because they
haven't fought anybody there's a couple
people you know I mean really I mean the
exception of John Jones whose only loss
is really pretty
illegally him with a [ __ ] down fist
yeah he's the exception everybody else
man it's like if I see a zero I'm saying
who have you fought do you think she
ever fights in the UFC again Oh
Rousey no I think whether UFC now it
doesn't matter if you're undefeated
it's about shrinks like John shrieks mal
way more than being undefeated and who
you be somebody and some of these guys
lost match early in their UFC career oh
yeah in their professional MMA career
and then they [ __ ] go on the shriek
like crazy like max Holloway has been
winning everything but good long time
something seems off with him huh
well he went through the healthcare
where people thought he was dying did
you see that interview yeah yeah it was
really weird it's like he was like
having a stroke in the middle of the
interview remember he wasn't a lot of
fight for a couple months because of
that yeah yeah yeah howdy better dude
Trudel I mean I was backstage a lot this
weekend and it seemed like a lot of
people were concerned
a lot of top people about Max's before
the frame yeah before the fight and I'll
tell you this is that everybody that was
concerned was no longer concerned after
the fight like it's like if that's it
that was fine if it looks and he jumped
over and started talking to Joe and it
was great yeah if he's at his smartest
in the Octagon if that's when he's the
most clear and decisive then so be it
good for business yeah hey man I mean it
was a great fight it was so funny
because I went to the wilder fight at
the Staples Center and they listed them
as having the exact same arm length and
when you saw them in the ring dude fury
had way longer arms and it looked like
he had way longer fight you know I mean
like they said they had the exact same
reach and it was obvious that Holloway
was way longer and that was the big part
of that was probably the biggest part of
the fight was just like picking up
picking off go I'm sorry I'll just say I
was just listening to that Deontay
Wilder was on Romans knew yeah looking
to half of it sounds like it seems like
a cool guy and he was like if you watch
it you see his Instagram where you put
the count yeah as a Long Count brow yeah
but the count doesn't start to the refs
starts account it's not when you hit the
mat it's when the ref starts County
that's two ten seconds he took him a
long time to get the word nine out of
his mouth you know yeah I mean like
that's why I don't have a problem with
the the draw because they both could
legitimately say I have no problem with
that draw I've no problem I'd love to
see that fight again it's the best
heavyweight fight we've seen in a long
[ __ ] very very long time very late Oh
what since what Linux probably so now if
you had a fight you could picked a fight
would you rather see fury versus Joshua
or uh or wilder versus John I'm thinking
fury he's a better boxer I'd rather see
their rematch first
yeah the rematch is way more and I think
Joshua still has to prove himself more I
think fury and while the prove
themselves to be one number one and two
I put Joshua number three I do
Joshua number three over wok because
wilder and fury five got Europe knocking
out white guys does mean
thing to me yeah doesn't mean Ethan
there done that yeah you're just
fighting white guys I mean I think I
think you guys are under reading Joshua
I think Joshua's great I think fury or
Waldo can both be Joshua I think very
and Wilder need to go at it again
beat beat the [ __ ] out of each other
again and then by the time that they're
recovered after that Joshua will be
ready to make a competitive fury the
best boxer out of the three yeah the
other two guys are definitely just a you
know power
all power and athleticism they they're
not great technical boxers they're not
at all they just have pure they're just
[ __ ] built like brick [ __ ] is
Joshua is a better boxer then whew Dana
yeah fury yeah
where's help all of them Deonte you know
he's just a knockout guy and he's got
that knockout pop and we don't talk
about this this was furious first fight
in what two years oh yeah since he lost
since he went crazy since he lost my
body weight basically yes he stopped
doing a KERS of coke and banging gypsy
[ __ ] I don't think he was doing that
I just think he was drinking and eating
and not giving a [ __ ] yeah I think just
oppression eating I mean he was almost
like 300 pounds did he say he was sure
he was eating crazy disgusting food yeah
Kane doesn't just make you gain weight
Yeah right am i right guys you know it's
like everybody I mean I work out but
it's like everybody's like God be chuka
it's like dude I'm a comic what do I got
be in shape I love this what I got be in
shape I tell jokes God who told you this
that you're so upset okay we're up
against like vegan [ __ ] rock you know
super cool everything is like so
controlled now there's no chaos yeah
that's how I feel I'm the only [ __ ]
comedian that's not sober on the whole
goddamn lineup anymore you have Bert
taking off his shirt starting drinking
as soon as he goes onstage I'm like this
is this is crazy is that functional if I
could function like that I be
it's there's only a few people left that
actually can have a [ __ ] few drinks
and a smoke before after Stanhope's like
four of them yeah he's keeping it real
dude I saw him once in the main room
about to go on stage do the fattest line
of cocaine I've ever seen a human being
do and then walk out and do an hour of
comedy who's this
Doug Sano oh I've never seen anybody do
that I would be dead if I had that
skills I don't think he I don't think he
could even perform not being drunk yeah
that's a big part of a lot I know a lot
of people that like they have to have a
couple beverages to go up that is the
one thing that's good about sobriety is
it lets you deal with that [ __ ] very
quickly I remember stand-up doing the
main room with a common story and you
just had like a cheap like like a fifth
yeah big handle of [ __ ] cheap ass
vodka really one of those plastic
handles and just [ __ ] drink the
entire thing but while doing a [ __ ]
hour on stage what's our and a half
what's your guys take on the whole Kevin
Hart thing is it something is it not
something the Oscars like whoo I mean
really definitely not I think we're
playing ourselves here I think this is
the Oscars way of letting us know that
the Oscars are coming up and I think no
better way to advertise something
nowadays then to book someone that you
know might have something in their past
they may have had this whole thing
figured out before they may have gone
seen some old tweets hired you got to
you got to ask yourself who has the
money to hire the PR to take something
like this down who who's paying for that
person to know the exact suite yeah well
it was basically that some was playing
with dolls he's like that's gay don't do
that that's gay and this was like
[ __ ] what trouble you're only 11 2010
and then they post stuff about Amy
Schumer and then he found Amy Schumer
and Sarah Silverman's like just calling
everybody [ __ ] and like nobody's
complaining about that right the good
thing is that Kevin Hart didn't
apologize he's like dude I'm not but
these they asked him to formally
apologize that Kevin Hart's like no I'm
not gonna apologize but somebody tweeted
I'm [ __ ] three tickets right now at
box-office is that really all it said
yeah
the Oscars Lisa's Cosmo Pete's having
heart more than Kevin Hart needs to
Hasmukh
no way gives a [ __ ] about the awesome
don't care it's trust fun kids [ __ ]
celebrating trust fund kids it's like
hey this movie about a [ __ ] guy who
fights to put glory holes in his [ __ ]
gay spa that's every [ __ ] it's all
indie flix now that nobody watches
that's a look at movie - oh what was
that
that's something seems like a movie you
with actin yeah I auditioned for it it's
just your [ __ ] well they wanted I
didn't that's right [ __ ] up because I
didn't I didn't know they'd he wanted
just my mouth so I just kind of
stretched open my [ __ ] and plucked it
up against this hole and uh he got a
callback
Teebs in the new movie glory hole nine
yards yeah glory hallelujah glory hole
nine inches whoa yeah I don't I think
that's stupid I just saw a thing that
was like oh he made these anti-gay
tweets a long time ago I'm like whatever
I love but then it's like who are you
somebody's anytime anybody gets anything
it's the Twitter troll police they're
just gotta be like all right get two
kids out let's cater better get your
laptop
let's read everything he's ever written
in the last [ __ ] ten years and let's
sift through it and find a way to ruin
it but like there's like the new there's
people in news that will just take a
screenshot of any tweet they think might
eventually be something and and they're
just cow logging you know cherish it
against people you know they're trying
to get no joke Eddie Murphy they want to
get Eddie Murphy do it does anybody seen
delirious oh yeah he says [ __ ] like
nine times blonde says he refuses to
kiss people cuz now you got to go home
with that eight [ __ ] aids on your lips
he says [ __ ] in his goddamn special
eye watches like that in here go like
[ __ ] it's unbelievably many times I
holy [ __ ] I say twice I say that's a
replacement Oscars that's the one you're
thinking about Eddie Murphy up dude
the whole thing is stupid you're Ari
winning in life you don't need another
award kiss my dick Eddie Murphy won't
wouldn't do it who would you get at this
point
tenacious d
you know who we should get let's get one
of these Twitter trolls up there that's
so perfect why don't you go do that
[ __ ] [ __ ] I hope they get Hannah
Gatsby and it just bombs
that'd be great I would love to watch I
would just watch for this I say max
hallo
no [ __ ] is cuckoo no I got it I put
out fallenness the white Howard perfect
oh you know loves the gays it wants to
be a comedian you know they got to get
the classic answer a black half [ __ ]
with no legs in a wheelchair you know
cross-dressing training [ __ ] his boner
about precious well no Boone says [ __ ]
too much they'll end up getting Tina Fey
and Amy Poehler and they will stock that
writers room with straight white males
in their 30s to 40s and they will do the
jokes right down the barrel easy breezy
negative Trump reference negative
reference their reality bump jokes you
know not only did they hire one woman to
do this tonight they hired two and the
women are so dumb and everybody gets an
award and that's the show welcome to the
Oscars it's the worst nobody knows the
movies Oscar voters even MIT they don't
watch the movies but imagine really
imagine Hannah Gatsby doing it first oh
I would like to say to all of you yeah
that this is the year where we change
things I put wigs on all the Oscars to
make them women so funny she hates men
yet she so desperately wants to look
like one yeah I thought she was I
thought it was James I thought she was
James Corden for a second she literally
looked like me am i special
Armageddon now yeah and this is the
weird thing I just talked about this
past weekend this is the first year that
I I don't know any of no one's talking
about any of the movies that it's cuz we
must foster ourselves but this whole
sequel [ __ ] every time you go see a
goddamn sequel you're supporting there's
another movie that's not in that theater
from a creative standpoint there's no
evolution we're not evolving anymore if
it's a suits dude they don't want to do
anything original it's either like task
whoa or weird [ __ ] on Adult Swim like
there's no like there's no one taking
chances on anything yeah it's like
bringing back every show that [ __ ]
where people were tired with we need to
take a stand like I was talking I know
med mr. T this past weekend we're
talking to him and apparently the guy is
like hey I have this thought so blah
blah blah blah like just gave four
things this is what I won and the guy
created the entire show on just four
thoughts who was include the creator of
the 1800 created the entire show like
all one guy military guys in a van it
was like small things like that and
Rocco Hawk no he he was buying soul food
for a mission hmm wondering if he still
keeps that mohaka of course he does six
years dude chuckle Adele's gonna have a
mohawk til he's like [ __ ] his pants
which will be two weeks from now yeah
which is this morning I would think that
like at some point in time like you'd
want to have like privacy you would just
grow it out how's that privacy because
you're not as recognizable what are we
[ __ ] Superman he's got glasses on we
don't know it's like chuckle doll with a
wig we know what the [ __ ] school I'm in
like even miss a Tia the Ricky would
still have all the gold chains on yeah
and you're like that's definitely mr. t
yeah that's I mean with a frog like
Cleveland you know yeah I don't know
how's mr. T's catchphrase again
apparently he said like a modern times
in conversation he's getting old now now
he says I shitty the pool yeah there's
just such [ __ ] Hollywood it's the
best time there's more opportunity and
it's just as unoriginal as possible you
there's more opportunities if you fit
what the company wants I want to say one
thing I'm super excited for TEDx and ro
because the guy got voted top ten comedy
specials on vulture which you know
vultures but that's still cool man I'm
super happy for that guy
ATC did is special here the
guys been grinding forever and it's good
to see a guy who's put in time get a
little recognition and I'm happy for him
you know the literally the whole
Restless was lesbians it's unbelievable
it yeah that's where they have a comedy
festival is pretty much it they just
it's amazing the most angry people on
the planet are the funniest ones the new
fun thing to look at is these lists and
anytime you see a straight what appears
to be a white male look and find the
thing that allows them to be on the list
whether they're gay whether it used to
be a woman whether it Jewish you know I
have deep deep challenge super super
Jewish it's gotta be extreme version of
something yes so that's something fun to
look out yeah and also and I'm always
like eating [ __ ]
nobody guys yeah there's no dude just
eating [ __ ] you know who is you know is
eating [ __ ] all the writers for all
those people on that list that you saw
well that's the great thing about these
female comics they're like oh the
finally female comics are gay it's like
they all hire male writers yeah all of
them every single performance you've
ever seen every award show everyone our
special every single thing there's so
here's that here's the clip that'll ruin
my career every single thing you've ever
seen a woman do yeah written by white
dude yep including all your SNL stars
including all your movie roles including
everything and their special Tina Fey
hundred percent that's the head writer
what do you mean she has a whole writers
room that's the that's the that's the
that's a writers room not only did she
have the SNL writers room then she had
the entire 30 rock writers room when you
when you're making a show and you see
someone that when you see the star of a
show doing anything else whether it's a
corporate event whether it's a this or
that they they have full access to the
the a team of at least twelve writers at
minimum that worked for them no matter
what else they want to do hey guys can
we take an hour and run jokes I have
this thing on Friday
night it's uh I have to make fun of the
military in San Diego so let's make fun
of the city let's make a few jokes about
that you know whatever it is and then
the room busts out for an hour an hour
times twelve writers you end up going
through a file for two hours getting to
pick your favorites and the whole job's
done because of one hour of real writers
yeah so and that's we're talking about
not only is she the star of a show and
I'm glad that we're using her as an
example because she's an EP and a head
writer and a listen to that you know
what I mean so that's a perfect example
of someone
same thing with Schumer Show has an
entire writers everything has a writers
room filled with you know whatever and
then they of course they you know they
have to make those a little bit diverse
to that's something fun that nobody
talks about to which is what is the
contribution of a lot of these other
people in a writers room well they get
value well people don't know that they
get less money on these diversity
contracts they get paid less for like
two or three years they got to take the
less money just to get in and it's I
think it's why I listen every you want
everybody to have a chance to get in and
then the best get it and whether that's
a a agen lesbian then let her in but
this diversity thing is basically saying
white guys are too good at this we gotta
[ __ ] cut them out so these other guys
can get a chance yeah the thing you like
if you have like the Sam Triplett show
good luck on that yeah like you have the
Sam Triplett show you're gonna bring in
writers that know your voice who can
write jokes in your voice who know who
you think are extremely funny and they
can write the jokes in your voice and
for you I feel like Italy B dudes yeah
yeah think there would be any women no I
mean there's some cheese I think our
who've Bonnie McFarlane I think is an
assassin yeah she's right solve her own
but it needs to be a bane of paczynski
SAS yeah it just needs to be people that
you can write in the voice the star of
the show and it doesn't matter what the
races or color or [ __ ] that's sad I
don't know and people flipped out yeah I
don't care what you're right are you
funny or not oh yeah
it's true and dude they get all these
shots and most him don't go anywhere I
mean Amy Schumer was just she's a trust
fund kid who's like related to the most
powerful politician in New York of
course she's gonna [ __ ] it and the
funny thing now is with all that help
with all this stuff and in the finish
line what does it end up being a
one-hour Netflix special and the catch
is here's where things sort of suck the
truth be told is that once here at that
final point the in the editing Bay even
if it wasn't funny they can turn up
those laughs and you'll notice those
fake that repeating sound of it almost
sounds too spread out perfect of a laugh
but you never hear that really in a
comedy club or a theater it's always
sort of like you know it's different
each laugh sounds different but now you
can just get away with murder because in
the editing Bay they'll just jack up
your laughs to way overboard which where
there's laughs on setups cuz the guy in
the editing Bay doesn't necessarily
always know how stand-up comedy works
evil that's what killed Comedy Central
yeah we're just hey I'm telling you
right now watch out because it's
happening on another platform big time
all right for sure
yeah for sure you know I didn't even try
to shop my special I just said [ __ ]
put it out and I'm just gonna make as
much money back as I can and then just
put it on YouTube
yep see there Netflix or YouTube that's
it I mean after that yep and for you if
you get if it gives you a couple more
weekends of road work then it's [ __ ]
worth it you know sure dude for sure I
just refused I like to find out what
they don't want me to talk about and I
just write hours on that just I'm going
hard [ __ ] you oh you know it's just like
I don't know these kids they hate
mean comedy they're also the ones who
want gun control yet they play [ __ ]
World of Warcraft the whole [ __ ] time
Sam Tribble you can't say you going hard
into commenting yet [ __ ] on everything
Tebow I said today whoa good job I'm
sorry Jason Josh you were great thank
you your lawyer [ __ ] won the case you
know our eating free you know Ari
special is it's called you you should do
it it's called [ __ ] Jews and just do a
whole hour of anti defined Jews on stage
in this town because everybody gets
quiet and it's just
ridiculous you should be able to make
fun of everybody it's weird they get
quiet exactly that's what it used to me
yes but it was white people doing it
white males doing it so you like oh
you're making fun of it everything used
to be funny everything used to be funny
trust fun kids whose parents were rich
made money off of [ __ ] evil [ __ ]
telling us to be nice it's [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up I mean I don't even think it's
that big of a thing I think it's just
people that want attention and that's
true too people want to make money and
oppression people want to be the one
that got and outrage whoever is the one
that got Kevin Hart whoever found that
thing in a blast that these people want
to go viral
they want their that's their way of
being famous is by being a fun internet
rat they just want to be Internet rats I
mean you know let's get into Ohio State
they kind of went through that right
where that whole thing with the coach
yeah it was a disgusting extension of
this me to movement where should the
head coach be fired for sort of hearing
something one time through his wife how
much of that is why you think he quit a
lot oh my god a lot it's ridiculous I'm
sure all that made his head headaches
happened even more often than a winning
program a great [ __ ] recruiting class
a high ranked [ __ ] team and he's not
an old guy being made out to look like a
devil and it all goes back to Joe
Paterno who was the real [ __ ] making
it so this could even be a storyline
type of thing is like he oversaw he
ignored these kids getting abused yeah
he did and that is bad but don't start
these new it's the new thing it used to
be American Idol America's Got Talent
the voice it's let's find a star and
make a star watch a star get made now
it's the opposite let's watch somebody
great at their job get [ __ ] up and
they love human anymore I'm making
everybody into liars yeah yeah they're
like [ __ ] chicks and those Reinke's
[ __ ] out idiots
those rants they like to that Paul
Finebaum would go off on at ESPN this is
the end of Urban Meyer it's gonna be a
matter of weeks and
we don't even know the whole story yet
you think Urban's not watching that you
think his wife's not watching that these
rants would that get all the hits
because everybody wants to click on this
is gonna be our bins last you know
Urban's last and the university's got to
do something this isn't it's not AM
radio ESPN is letting these buffoons go
and they're a total hypocrite right
they can't celebrate Kobe and Peyton
Manning enough right
both have been accused of awful [ __ ]
[ __ ] Kobe basically came out and said he
did it yeah and then they can't stop
bring him on getting their thoughts on
this and at the same time acting like
great Hardy trying to find it just
listening if you [ __ ] up your [ __ ] up
man
but you deserve a second chance yeah
like Randy Gregory [ __ ] up a Milton
and now he's finally somewhat clean and
[ __ ] doing great for the Cowboys yeah
people deserve second chances if they
[ __ ] it up like Lewis CK like the guy
deserves a second chance
and if he [ __ ] it up you're gone yeah
give Louis a whack at it
yeah I mean John Jones had five chances
yeah you know certain skill and he's the
best at it the problem is that everybody
thinks they're funny and anybody can be
a comic so they just really try to
replace this with people it's like it's
what the funny bones do they don't want
to pay anybody to play their clubs
because they think I mean I would go top
they paper the room now the whole room
is paper yeah nobody buys tickets to
their thing because they diminish your
products so badly right no that's weird
it's really weird you know it's funny
with Kobe I did it where did I see this
but I'd been just some interview about
him or an article I read about him but
you know after all of that rape thing
happen you know that that's when he got
the nickname black mamba and you know
who gave him that nickname himself so
you just got I thought was the girl here
a you just got accused of rape and then
to [ __ ] hype yourself up your
nickname is a giant black snake that
makes me hate him even oh absolutely it
does but you to abayas you get get
Lakers you can't get I hate I like the
Lakers now more than I did
Lakers are looking good
fun to watch I don't like the Lakers I
don't like the Lakers no but I like I
could watch them now more than I could
watch when Kobe Johnson Shaq or two of
my favorite players of all time
Jackie my therapy for first Shaq as a
Laker or Shaq as a magic
I mean Shaq as a Laker was dominant
magic chakras magic magic was great with
was without really far the way LeBron
James when he was just ripping rims off
and [ __ ] back - you all haven't seen
a 7-foot guy move like that I was I saw
a gift the other day somebody posted a
it was like that time Shaq dunked on an
entire NBA team and I forgot all about
it but there's all five guys trying in
the lane stop it all jumping and
reaching at once and this [ __ ]
just duty was tending like no one
dominant at LSU if he had discipline he
would have just destroyed ambien he
would be the greatest player of all time
I used to work out of McDonald's and uh
he was all Shaq would go through our
drive-thru at the McDonald's I work out
yet family like nearby and he would just
order like four [ __ ] Big Macs I'd
love to hear you two going back and
forth over the boys boxes can you repeat
that again look in the middle okay no
I'm gonna be honest with you he's the
only one to ever tip me in the
drive-through like here's the extra
Twitter I know you working hard one of
the best businessmen outside of Michael
Jordan you keep the jury in the NBA like
him LeBron hardly - it's probably now
later Barclays to coach but I remember
seeing Shaq when I was ten years old and
I was like super tiny and I saw me in
the New Orleans Airport and [ __ ] dude
was [ __ ] massive yeah holy [ __ ] I
didn't know like you ain't realized you
with that big in person am I holy [ __ ]
like I remember seeing uh Kevin Nash the
pro wrestler and he's like 611 I think
yeah 350 pounds yeah I'm like holy [ __ ]
yeah
and tracks bigger than that yeah checks
even bigger than that Shaq so good at
business that sometimes commercials of
him will go back-to-back like Gold Bond
that guy will sell anything
insurance general and sure that's such a
rinky-dink thing like how much money
could they have given Shack Oh a lot of
money I heard a thing about those three
of them that are on TNT yeah uh-huh
did you hear about how much money they
make no Neal Brennan was telling me
about this so who all is it's it's Shaq
Shaq
Kenny ah Kenny Thompson now and Barkley
Barkley Kenny Smith Kenny Smith yeah
Barkley under new Johnsonville not none
of them make more than 12 grand per
episode really yep oh that's weird
it's that much but they have so many
episodes that they make their money on
don't they tape it like one one of them
makes like four one of them makes eight
one of them makes ten one of them makes
twelve checks probably makes the most I
think I can probably or the higher I
think it's shags and Barkley yes no
doubt about it
but dude look at what that's afforded
them oh I know it makes I just keep
basketball want to watch I don't even
know if that's good or bad really if
relatively it's just when you see a show
like that you really have no idea if I
ask you to guess what would you have
guessed how much they make in per
episode it's oily ah ha that's a great
quite I'm gonna do it all the time I
think about this a lot with Joe Rogan
what do they do 20 wonder how much UFC's
paying him and he you know only does the
ones that he wants to do now right yeah
so he's that he doesn't have to go to
Brazil or whatever yeah nope I don't
even think he's doing I don't even think
he goes that's a man in comedy yeah it's
between him I think in Tom Segura Tom
Segura is a [ __ ] brilliant
businessman yeah well I mean Joe paved
the way for Tommy the tree of Rogan yeah
I mean the tree of rogue is the host of
Fear Factor yeah I mean come on bend at
the knee I mean dude the guy's batting
average has to be what 900 950 it's
insane but I'm wondering how much UFC
pays him right isn't that a great
question like heard that one time how
much longer do you think he has on that
I think they've asked they
probably I know he like he was talking
about leaving five years ago that's what
I mean yeah he's always kind of hinted
at that and I wonder how much this ESPN
thing is gonna send him which way if I
was him I wouldn't be is been thing
doesn't affect him at all because he
only does the paper page effect well my
guess would be if ESPN doesn't change
much of the format and lets their people
stay at the UFC and they let them keep
that family feel and they let UFC really
produce it instead of ESPN ting it up
it's definitely gonna help keep them
there that's right because everything
has an effect and they they want you
want to keep that family tight even when
WME came in like they did a pretty
decent job at keeping the core those
ever Goldberg well I think that was all
they get but show that belters but I
really do think that man they decide who
can we lose that won't really damage the
brand and every fighter they lose is
like number four or five so it's big
enough to be like whoa they got blah
blah blah they got Ryan Bader you like
holy [ __ ] but it's not enough to hurt
the product do you know I'm saying yeah
I mean a lot of that too is like them
you know don't say cleaning out the
division but them willing to be like hey
we're not gonna read something Bader
welcome to the podcast Joey Diaz how are
you hey Joey
let me see huh I'm on podcast I love you
punk rock I'll call you after I'll
follow up with you and what comes from
the bottom no no no he has we don't know
where the Jew is right now he's
wandering yeah throwing rocks at
Palestinians
yeah for sure have you seen Israeli
twerking videos they're top-shelf all
right dude I love you death I want call
yo on I want to talked about something
I'll call you after bye bud Wow great
the great Joey Diaz
you just never know who will call in and
be pissed I put him on speakerphone
heavyweight champion the champion did
the hardest guy to follow up The Comedy
Store
I enjoyed following him oh dude I mean
when he hits no you got about five
minutes being Charlie Brown's mom you
have to won't won't won't won't want and
they're like oh my god you see that it's
a fun way to follow I kind of like it
because I follow him in the main room a
couple times during red bands show and I
was like it's not easy but it's fun is
there not a lot of energy so if you can
if you if you go off of it and slow it
down and make the audience listen you
can do good what's harder in my opinion
to follow is someone with just that just
matches that cadence and silliness like
a Theo von when he just stays in the
pocket and he's just saying funny funny
[ __ ] every four to five seconds funny
words yeah my funny retrospect you know
have you met Vaughn's number-one
impersonator they may appreciate that oh
wow hi Theo yeah I'm just trying to stay
right with Christ you know ma'am
hahahaha got all these Hillbillies
trying to get get him up you know
getting it on my snacks
I think Holtzman's are tough one two
because he they don't even know what
just happened you know you almost have
to start over from scratch following you
know you have to reset the room after
you happen because and it's not an easy
reset at all yeah that's what I mean
there's no real wiggle room in there
because you're gonna be so different
from Holtzman everybody is if he kills
it's such a weird reset mustache just
[ __ ] complete and his belt all the
way up to his [ __ ] what I love about
Diaz is just if you follow Diaz and
you can go dirty early into your set
following Diaz it's easier to go start
with dirty stuff or some very [ __ ] up
weird [ __ ]
that's why I [ __ ] love tears we could
think I'm like I don't want the pan
there with some boring stuff to ease
into the dude I to follow him and a Joe
Rogan show doing ten minutes of the best
asset material I've ever heard my life
yeah which I always said it's like
filing Joey Diaz and Joe Rogan shows
like middling for Van Halen the opening
act as David Lee Roth right I mean he's
just [ __ ] murdering I'm like what am
I gonna talk about right you know him
and Lisa Lampanelli for me of the two
people I've had just memorable bombs in
the in the 19 years I've been the commie
stories like they stuck they left marks
with me yeah but most people like
there's some people I follow I'm like
wow that went a lot easier than I
thought was gonna do and they're [ __ ]
destroy like Chris D'Elia for some
reason I do well after I don't know why
you know I needs a master what he does I
love what he does you can't you know not
everybody can be Doug stamp you don't
want all Doug stamp you want a [ __ ]
spectrum right yeah of course I love
what Chris D'Elia does he's a monster
he's a bad mom so good at his style and
a monster yeah he's a good dude man
yep that's a guy that really uh really
won me over man in the beginning you
know it's tough for me to be immediately
amazed by a person that I know like has
family in the business and came from
money and this and that so it's also
like always nice oh we're never not nice
always nice he's the kind of classic
example of somebody if he was an [ __ ]
he would be so hated by everybody
because he's had everything yeah I mean
right but he's so [ __ ] nice and he's
super funny yeah I mean he's been kind
to everybody Bryan Callen is like the
Bruce Springsteen of Santa he's so funny
to watch them their mannerisms are the
exact same they whether they win on
stage a couple times together and it was
just D'Elia making fun of Bryan Callen
they're they're fun group to those two
men those guys are both funny they're
hilarious how many girls you think they
DP'd together
before director i'll camera that I'll
[ __ ] cameraman that the [ __ ] frozen
see right there Jokke remember Oh Callan
put up this video of [ __ ] like
FaceTime [ __ ] message or something
that [ __ ] D'Elia sent and he's just
got his shirt off and he keeps walking
back and forth you know every now and
then I'll give like a move like he's
gonna fight him and counts doing a play
by play of and he's like what is he
doing here see same move right there
he's doing the same [ __ ] uppercut
what is it
and then he just holds up this little
dog just holds it never says anything
and then the video ends he goes what is
he gonna do with that dog throw it at my
throat it's so stupid dude never fun man
those guys are fun the tree of Rogan is
very powerful there will be a [ __ ]
book a movie about it yeah it's pretty
amazing and you got even got a factor I
mean I know he's got the biggest podcast
if there is but between the end of
October and last week yet both Tyson
Fury and Deontay Wilder on his [ __ ]
podcast to talk about the fight before
and then the fight everybody I know it's
amazing
he gets everybody he's gonna have fun
you know he's hey did with great power
comes great responsibility man and like
I know I would flame throw that whole
thing what do you mean I would get that
big I'd say some crazy the whole thing
would crash he's pretty good about just
not giving a [ __ ] it'll just do whatever
and say whatever people like that you
know I'm musting I'm like are you
worried about anything I don't care I'm
not worried about nothing I mean amazed
that's scare that could have been scary
in some way I would be they've been
scary if it was on TV
I don't think each other then it would
be yeah but what can you how can you
take that away for it's his [ __ ] Park
I said he puts out on his own dude you
came on your way to and the government
is investigating them
that's scary [ __ ] I tell you this right
now okay last thing you want Joe doing
is having that thing on TV in any way or
never anything right when the whole
thing is that it's cool it's cool
because you find it it's cool why this
is cool it's cool why kill Tony's you
know and I think a lot of people and by
a
I mean even us sometimes forget how cool
it is that it's not over produced and
that it's not spoon feeding them this
goes for every and it's just wrong
that's why I like I'm a big fan like
Legion skanks because it's very raw all
[ __ ] calm those guys are very funny
yeah yeah they're funny guy but it's
just very raw and think Brit Rogan as
well it's a lot of raw conversation
that's not pre-planned no bareback
yeah am i right guys there's no real
setup just [ __ ] we just go with it
you know you don't have that when you do
this you don't have that like overlord
of somebody being like hey the
advertisers don't want you to do this
and even with the suits it's happened I
gotta go we're like you know we you know
we've done weird reads or we were just
being funny we're being ourselves and we
know what our audience likes and when
advertisers like hey you know you know
we don't then cool kick rocks then we
don't then don't work with us it works
cuz there's no format at all it's the
opposite of like pardon the interruption
where you know everything that's coming
up next yeah the part of that type of
unproduced podcast feel is you ow you on
musk is on we don't know what they're
gonna talk about maybe they will talk
about spaceships maybe they'll smoke pot
and maybe they'll talk about it'll just
be about their kids for some reason for
sure may know the fact that we don't
know what's coming up and we don't know
what's gonna happen the minute you know
they add a segment to that show where
it's like all right it's time for Jill
Rogen's top ten and a week you know
that's when it'll start to be like what
producers like it gets you drawn in
without a single word being said yeah
like nothing nothing says you like this
is a guest that's all you know and you
wanna watch because you don't know what
the I want to do the first podcast where
nobody talks hey might be your most
successful a lot of people want you to
do that everybody on the show right now
I bet you know if you want make it back
go to Bette DSi Betty aside for all your
Betty needs they're our longest-running
sponsors and they've been kind enough to
stick with us um it's very cool
you go to Betty I use the promo code
punch 25
they'll get you 25 dollars betting cash
and whatever you deposit up to $500 they
will match that's amazing that is
amazing and it's a wonderful time to be
gambling dude there's more yeah there's
more information on gambling like
gambling is full-on taking over sports
talk radio sports television yeah I mean
like you can make money get Killian is
killing it
yeah he knows he knows his MMA he does
know but here's the thing he posts only
when he went right you know I mean you
never see him like I'd like to see him
do that like hey I lost 3 grand on this
fight what would that around like if he
did about basically even right now every
gambler
we are you up or down yeah I won like
three then I lost like 28 another 1,500
and then you're just saying numbers did
turn it pretty much 27:55 yeah I mean
what that means basically even my dad do
that what blackjack lose like ten hands
and row I'm like dad how you doing Oh
even I'm like dude you dad you're taking
no gamblers ever even right either down
or up then you're almost always down
yeah yeah and when you say you're even
you're down yeah I did pretty good on my
picks this week of course I went with
Yoanna and why would you bet against
yourself right exactly
I always bet ik for my people but other
than that I there was another shocker in
there the one that surprised me I almost
had a hit out parlay on DSi and I don't
know like 1 2 but the [ __ ] it Miami
game [ __ ] me oh dude that was so much
fun to watch oh I love watching it can
we talk about how the Raiders can't even
lose right oh yeah I can't lose right I
mean dude nobody's winning that name
game no business winning that game it's
the dumbest [ __ ] thing but that's
bigger than is that maybe Corey rulings
might be getting on the same page I'll
know median is gone Game of Thrones on
the [ __ ] Raiders cars got be like hey
back tire GM's
yeah they fire the GM dude
the only one ever be fired after a win
oh no it's a good question Oh the GM for
the Raiders yeah they fired him after
win Wow
Vikings fired their offensive
coordinator last name my Saints are
number one but where we belong
thanks for the bear gonna be interesting
to see what happen have you guys already
talked about how some mashing this
college football playoff is gonna be
what a sad joke it is I think it's I
think the college the college playoffs
needs to go to six weeks but eight would
be better because they're getting the
same people give em a lie
yeah so can I have the body for the top
no yeah I'm okay then you can see UCF
and have UCF lose and so they can stop
talking [ __ ] I think a room for a Notre
Dame and I'm gonna for Oklahoma oh my
god okay you got you poor guys welcome
I'm sorry all 64 team football that'd be
murdering it's a March Madness but
football I'm sorry about the take
Alabama and Clemson with the point I
mean just take them all the way they are
going to Alabama's gonna win by 90 yeah
they're going to destroy Notre Dame in
Oklahoma it's not worth watching at all
and then they ruin the Rose Bowl by
leaving Ohio State out to because now
Ohio State's gonna what smell oh what a
great story for Urban Meyer to go away
on top he's retiring
he's got they ruined his brain there's
the less he broke that man but he's
coaching their their bowl game yeah yeah
what is ball what balls Ashington is a
low fifty five to seven fifty five to
seven maybe fifty five to three
what a joke they ruin everything they're
in the Rose Bowl though that's what
they're doing yeah yeah it's not the
real Rose Bowl with these playoffs it's
a joke we beat number four Michigan we
slaughtered them 64 230 something about
that I mean I like Ohio State but man I
just want to see Missy get one no no no
and it's not gonna happen next year
either I'm gonna tell you right now I'm
gonna be the FIR
person on this show to tell you wait
until you guys meet a man named Ryan day
boy are you gonna love him who's Ryan do
you know he's a coach that Ohio State
once knew he's been the offensive we're
gonna [ __ ] love what's about to
happen at Ohio State Oh every time he's
on this show Oh
last time he said we're gonna love what
happens this year his [ __ ] coach his
[ __ ] children and what I'm gonna [ __ ]
just happened oh you have no idea well
look what we did again and I feel bad
for you Michigan fans that are excited
that I didn't leaving because this guy
coming up Ryan day is more evil than
even I can comprehend my friends this
guy hates everything and hates everyone
and is out to prove a [ __ ] point and
that's a guy I'm talking about a guy
that might be the answer to Nick Saban
it might be the answer to Davos weenie
cuz once these kids see what this guy is
all about it's nasty a lot like what
Stoops and Lincoln Riley just did at
Oklahoma but this kid's disgusting he's
a nasty dude with bad intentions
Overmeyer ever coach again don't go to
the NFL which he denies no I
wholeheartedly that he doesn't want the
Browns job I think he'll take a one-year
deal I think in not this upcoming year I
think he'll take a year off he'll do the
desk again and then I think he'll take a
nap yes PN that just destroyed him yeah
I think yeah he will and I think he'll
take a nasty one or two-year deal with
with some crazy school might even be USC
might be like a freak competitor that's
been like a different a different
conference yeah yeah can you see could
you ever see him going back to the SEC
like Tennessee no he'll he can make the
pac-10 decently help it get a little bit
stronger again and God knows they need
it USC should throw their entire
checkbook at him I don't know what they
would anyways I can see that and it's
Southern California the kids are growing
right so I
why not it takes that Browns job he
doesn't even have to sell his house
being in Ohio's toxic though and for
what just happened to him I'm sure he's
looking to get out if he's gonna get out
he doesn't want to be reminded of Ohio
sports
he got what happened to him this year
was one of the saddest things and all
the bombs gone they're the biggest brand
in Ohio what the Buckeyes yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure and if he stayed in Ohio
he goes to market to buy food and
there's someone who the Ohio State fed
try to talk to him people all the [ __ ]
time people don't realize how big oh hi
Oh state really is in Ohio I think this
state bars in different cities and you
see the people man I know so many people
from Ohio but in Ohio look there's a
bunch of major cities first of all we
decide who's president every year we
basically sort of set the trends in
everything and the point is is with all
the major cities there in the biggest
city doesn't have an NFL team we have
two NFL teams the Cincinnati Bengals the
Cleveland Browns and Columbus doesn't
have a football team why when they're
twice as big as Cleveland and Cincinnati
it's because they we don't we don't want
them we don't even want the bangles on
the Browns it's been the Buckeyes
forever there's no doubt that that and
every Browns and Bengals fan is a
Buckeye fan and it's bigger than even
that
so Ohio doesn't you know one Cincinnati
they are a city Cincinnati no I
it's very country we call it sensitive
claimant I call it country ghetto that's
why I'm like upstate New York his
country [ __ ] ghetto like hood [ __ ]
rednecks Cincinnati's one of the worst
cities on the planet and upstate I went
to Chipotle there I felt like I was in
the wire
it was the I'm like dude everybody's
getting shanked in here Wow Bobby
speaking of long streaks pulling
Cincinnati I'll leave one in your under
ed was I just realized uh with
sponsorship for like these bowl games
the Fiesta Bowls no longer responsible
or Tia's or whatever the tortillas if
the place tortillas fee is the
PlayStation
i ball playstation fiesta bowl does not
fit at all playstation is what it is yes
playstation fiesta dude they're just
awful oh those hands are empty I'm like
why is this on national television when
the people there don't even want to
watch it yeah
welcome to the PlayStation Fiesta Bowl
live from Value City Arena with the one
and only Mountain Dew dash cam dude
Gareth Reynolds has the best bit we're
like they're just gonna start working
advertisements into play by plays oh
yeah you know for sure dude the dr.
pepper pile on the pylon cam yep you
know what I hate on Monday Night
Football is this booger McFarlane the
chair thing that he's on it just rolls
over why do we care what he thinks
because his name's booger what and we
why does he get the smile like that
people don't understand it I don't know
how you got the job who picked booger
come on nobody knows what booger jokes
nobody knows oh well you got a dig deep
to pick booger it makes no sense to me
who do you guys think I'm sorry oh we
haven't talked much NFL at all and this
is well who's your team do you think is
the unstoppable team this year do you
think there is an unstoppable team you
guys are gonna be tough unstoppable you
guys are gonna be tough to play in New
Orleans come on it's the LA Rams I think
I think golf show the he's a young
quarterback
I think the Bears yes the exact same
thing I think the Bears just crack the
safe on the Rams have given you a
blueprint of how to beat him but this
thing lights the [ __ ] out of being
stopped girly with the girl we had what
56 yards rushing give this thing nothing
for girly basically the Raiders
basically made three teams playoff teams
I mean well Janikowski the funny thing
is like a [ __ ]
the Cowboys trade they traded him today
traded Cooper to the Cowboys
thinking full-on there are two and four
team right now that look like [ __ ]
that's gonna be a very high draft pick
and now they're about to win the
division this kid's got 700 yards and
Ikes and the thing we made with the
Bears picks for Khalil Mack is just
going to be a Lake [ __ ] pig they're
gonna have like for the last [ __ ]
seven picks yeah they traded him to they
traded him to the Bears because they
thought the Bears the Niner is one of
them and they're like now the Niners are
gonna be good
we're not gonna trade him to the Niners
will turn with the bears because bears
are gonna suck
bears are what we've been in their
division and the major injury though
they'd have a first pick overall
they lost Garoppolo which ruined the 9th
there's the the river should have them
first and second pick
can you imagine back grab Majan haven't
won and to you the Scotty the Bose is so
badly and they just keep [ __ ] this up
he's gonna go high [ __ ] purebred
Buckeye now do you think losing him hurt
your guys season yeah what about the
goddamn NFL lineman he would have
definitely tackled the quarterback for
Purdue oh stop it don't say that word
that's what [ __ ] you huh
what's the only [ __ ] thing that
[ __ ] us was one bad satyr I was in
Toledo Ohio and there's a lot of
Michigan fans in Toledo but it's closed
yeah and [ __ ] arm everyone was
watching the game and everyone was so
happy oh I thought bar the common club
what was that that's amazing they all
[ __ ] hate Ohio say even though
they're in Ohio they Michigan's not that
I was like why netiquette doing a casino
gig that I really didn't want to do that
I like agreed to a year before like it
was booked like way out and was this
dreadful gig that I really I mean really
didn't want to do
I kept flying to the east coast during
this time a couple months ago every
weekend I was just going Connecticut
Boston New York Toronto I was just over
it and for that to happen there I mean
it was just devastating was one of those
ones where literally I kept uh instead
of recording my set on my phone you know
and you have like the big timer and
everything and I'm doing an hour to
write so so instead of having
recorder on I just kept the stream going
and I would glance over at at times and
literally just go [ __ ] during the middle
of my sub they didn't know what I was
talking about did you say you had
Tourette's right no literally truly how
it went until the very end until the end
and I you know basically told them the
truth I go you know this entire time
I've been watching one of my favorite
sports teams get shockingly B yes
multitasking they loved it they loved it
too because everything they thought I
was pure evil at that point Connecticut
worst comedy fans in the world and if
you're wondering really just go to
Connecticut where that what's up would
say uh Tony Hinchcliffe fan was he look
like smart hard-working defender reaiiy
have the smartest comedy fans because I
do not know there's going to be his
answer was I have a show I think I'm
triply shopped in a lot of salton I have
a show about comedy show team comedians
talk to comedians about comedy so I have
the biggest comedy fans that go see
everybody and support live shows a lot
and that you know live their dreams and
love winning and being a winner and
rooting for the winning side and yeah my
people are the best Mike Adamle fans
just look like Jason Tebow yeah
and that those are my comedy fans so
you're [ __ ] you're super [ __ ] kid
Danny what's up with you how was your
wait where were you boss Danny come on
man we had a streak on where she was
gonna talk to her that's what happened
to admire - yeah maybe we're like fine
no the whole show I was like I don't
know what to do yeah like Armageddon
[Laughter]
although Kevin sounds like what you get
after you eat too much Taco Bell ya know
that I Sunday I'll be in the belly room
it's Sam when you start crying do you
call it emo gettin you bouquet
I only cry when I jerk off I only cry
when you jerk off what else we want to
talk about you see how the reps
completely [ __ ] that game last night
what game the money and I came to
Seattle versus Minnesota refs are bad
because we have so very bad this year
it's six to nothing about eight minutes
left
Minnesota's kicking a field goal to cut
it to a three point game and a
linebacker for Seattle jumps over the
line blocks the kick but you're not
allowed to launch didn't kill I can't
jump off of your back right you're
anything like that he so clearly uses
both of his hands to push off of two
guys and get over the line yeah don't
know call block the kick then they get
the ball right there go down scored
touchdown games pretty much over they
got a meaningless defensive touch no man
at the end of the game but that was
nothing
yeah I mean the rough suck that was my
problem with the Saints Cowboys game is
the helm and the helmet here though in
Camaro that was on and that [ __ ] us
that you know call know called all then
he gets fine he is fine like $40,000 23
yeah 23 23 I think that is so [ __ ] up
that you cannot penalize a player for
something but then and then find him for
it later
that's rest of all you ever been with a
buddy and you're banging the same chick
and your dicks accidentally touch I call
that helmet-to-helmet infraction yeah I
do it well I do that all the time enough
that you've decide to name it
whoopsie-daisy
no it happened again I do that all the
time with my buddies but without girls
yeah helmet to helmet a little flag out
of my g-string that I always wear you do
wear I thought you just went jockstrap
like a champion I wear a g-string and I
just pull my dick and balls to the side
and let it out like a [ __ ] I like I
like that we got balls and one side dick
on you I like doing a [ __ ] split yeah
yeah we call that we call that the old
bag of bones I like that uh-huh I like
that
yeah man [ __ ] hot gay sex am i right
there's nothing better it's a
[ __ ] good time so [ __ ] good we
got a we got a slogan for it a sex
it's a [ __ ] but [ __ ] good time
but [ __ ] yourself a smile today yeah
who loves gay sex if you go to gay sex
calm right now and enter the homo code
yeah use the homo code but sex punch 121
struck 69 let's root punch 166 brunch
drunk is anybody hurt Jason Collins new
podcast it's so [ __ ] funny it's
called promo code and each one's about
six minutes and all he does is talk
about whatever fake advertising dude
today we're talking about what was it
called Shazam's euros not year as what
was it calzones Shazam's calzones
that's our sponsor today shazam didn't
you [ __ ] think this guy was locked in
a basement making [ __ ] calzones it's
all he talks about is so funny dude I
love that his new and it's called medium
speed internet I'm excited to hear what
that one is about yeah dude he's great
yeah check out Jason's podcast called
albums great - he said I love watching
him perform ah he's one of my absolute
favorites he's you know especially all
of us have known each other forever we
all have seen each other's act backwards
and forwards and all he's one of the
ones that like you can still watch it
and laugh at the jokes that you know are
coming for sure do that I mean for sure
it's fun to watch people watch him for
the first time who have you watched that
you felt was [ __ ] at first and I was
like holy [ __ ] he's gotten really good
that's a really big deal there's certain
comedians that are like that you know of
course like this summer growers and
summer shower
Bobby Lee you remember Bobby Lee well he
was not that good of a comic when he was
first around wonderful I think we're
talking about two different things
there's some people that have gotten
better
all right and then there's some people
whose styles the first time you see them
you're like what is this guy's problem
why in there and then you realize that
they're actually like that like Brody's
a big one you show somebody bro
for the first time you your friend that
you took in there like hey you got to
see this guy afterwards will literally
be like what the [ __ ] was that but once
they see Brodie a second time it's their
favorite comedian yeah oh yeah that's
another one exactly well somewhere on
Barris I'm yeah ding dong Jeff so like
that yep
the first time you see them you think
they're having a meltdown like a
breakdown they're like the first time I
saw the ding dong show I had no idea
what the [ __ ] was going on oh dude I
didn't either I was like I don't got
honest at all the first times like why
is this guy going up yeah and then I
would talk [ __ ] and then I saw him and I
got it and I like for a year I had to
apologize to him because he's super he's
a wonderful dude he's super hilarious
like a diabolical genius like the way he
plays these guy and you could sit there
and be like oh he's picking these people
know what's going on and they're
enjoying it and then you just find see
psycho hot chicks that just run around
with him I saw when I first saw him like
I don't think I get this I mean I don't
know why everybody now you're smarter
than me it was smart you don't mean oh
yeah my window of comedy was so just
like punchlines like that's really the
thing to keep an eye out for in the
comedy world is like if somebody's in
the game successfully and you don't
quite get it but it's not hacky yeah
then there's probably something more to
it yeah yeah that's exactly what that
was when I first saw sure yeah for sure
I mean he's so [ __ ] funny and what's
it Mary Jane yeah he's wonderful were
the nicest people ever and she gets it -
yeah it's sometimes it's not sometimes
it's always it's always better to be
smarter than everything that they've
already seen before
if that makes sense well I just think
there's so many comics now yeah it's
like it's so hard
that's why I've gone heal bro I went bad
guy I committed to it I come out
bragging from the get now I give them my
perspective I put either you're with me
or you're against me if you're against
me I'm about to win you over and if
you're with me let's [ __ ] party but I
don't even hold back anymore
I basically have committed more towards
in the past year to the character that
teeb does of me then then even how I was
before it's a weird way saying thank you
for his career yeah yeah thanks to you
yeah I've been able to actually make
money that makes one of us
Tony's making money off my impression of
Tony yeah voice old Tony he needs to be
Lex Luthor enough talking Joker yeah
everybody sees a Joker coming yeah Lex
Luthor does more damage yeah but he also
gets to live in a penthouse bang [ __ ]
top-shelf yeah ass and [ __ ] have a
great career the [ __ ] Joker is in the
[ __ ] gutter
you know betta [ __ ] be Lex Luthor
yeah I never really understood that and
I've always asked you like well what do
you mean but I'd never I still don't get
it one day it's gonna click I'm gonna be
like what I'm saying is is that it's you
can be evil you just can't let them know
you're being it you know what I'm saying
like if yours blunt-force obvious with
it everybody sees it's coming like it's
just the way it is is anybody gonna want
help or anybody you know stuff like that
down the road I think now that you know
you've gotten so much success you've
calmed down
yeah you're still the dude but now
you're calm down you're not you're more
like you you're more of a thinking evil
than the [ __ ] I must say mean [ __ ]
ever you know that was it was before
right that's the Joker
and now the my new misdirect is that
it's a little there's times where it's
more wholesome and another finish that I
come out in and and basically play evil
so this way when I do talk about
something a little more wholesome but
maybe about my wife or something like
that like it's like whoa look at that
we've seen his evil side so this is
funny because this is yeah normal side
so it's like I flipped it a little bit
fun to watch dude I'm really happy for
you man you [ __ ] focus yeah guys
everybody go to your European and kill
Tony yeah we'll check out kill Tony kill
Tony TV death squad dog be fun to see
how European does because their Styles
so different some Saints like what we
were doing in the 80s and they're trying
to catch up yeah
see nanny Manny really went off today
you went crazy almost rainy oh yeah see
you guys I'll be difficult the plug one
thing I just realized this upcoming
Sunday at the Comedy Store 3 p.m. we are
reps or pro wrestling podcast ever you
do we're doing a live commentary
watching table a lot of chairs and do
live come and check it out man if you've
ever enjoyed pro wrestling before in
your life you should come to the comedy
store this Sunday we're downstairs in
the belly room we watch we watch the
paper views on a projector and we mute
the sound and we do the commentary yeah
so another being mostly just roasting
see us all cracking each other so even
minutes even when it's bad is [ __ ]
great for us oh you pro wrestler former
champion David Arquette is going to be
joining us all right Aaron I'm almost
done hold on real quick with the
punch-drunk is having another UFC event
at the end of the and at the end of the
year at the Sycamore tavern for Jon
Jones fight punch trunks John Jones
fight come we do all we watch the fights
and then we have stand up after so come
to it's a 29th I'll have those tickets
up now is it ok if I come to that I want
yeah yeah super fun come be a part of
the I'll be in town ok welcome everybody